what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and we just watched miss
marvel episode three and we have a lot
to talk about for this episode as a lot
was revealed and made clear now but a
lot of new questions have come up as
well like who exactly are the gin they
seemed good at first and they seemed
really nice to kamala but then of course
they were bad trying to get the bengal
and it makes you wonder if they truly
are bad or if they're just doing what it
takes to get back home also of course we
have to talk about the ending of episode
3 where kamala saw the train but also
her grandmother did as well and now she
has to go to pakistan and we have
finally learned some majorly important
things about kamala's bengal in this
episode it was revealed that there are
two which basically confirms that these
are indeed the nega bands and they are
connected to the mcu in ways that we
didn't think about before so let's dive
right into it and of course if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest mcu videos
so right away let me know what you
thought about miss marvel episode 3. i
think there were a lot of great moments
in this episode and i really actually
enjoyed the wedding scenes i think it
was really fun and i think it was
actually pretty touching but
unfortunately the gin had to come and
screw it all up and we have learned that
the jinn are from a different dimension
this is important to know because this
is actually what kamala is her great
grandmother was jin and kamala's
grandmother was also with jin as well
now the jin are invisible creatures and
early pre-islamic arabian religious
systems and later in islamic mythology
and theology they are basically
characterized broadly as spirits or
demons and as najma explained they are
from the nord dimension and we learned
that nor means light so they are
claiming that they are from the light
dimension however it is explained pretty
clearly that they were exiled from the
nord dimension now there are many
different things that could get you
exiled and this whole group of gins that
we meet in this episode don't exactly
seem like the best people however i
would like to believe that kamala's
great grandmother was somewhat good and
maybe the exile was due to some type of
miscommunication or misunderstanding
although her friends don't seem that
good and even when they go to the
wedding comrad says that they will kill
them all and think about that for a
second these people will kill innocent
people who are celebrating love at a
wedding that means they're pretty bad
people but let's talk about this opening
scene because it is extremely important
and it's important for three major
reasons and i'm talking major reasons it
is really connecting the mcu in ways we
didn't think yes of course it is the
marvel cinematic universe but things
haven't seemed that connected recently
however kevin feige just a couple of
days ago said that in the next few
months we will start to see the bigger
picture and how everything is going to
connect and we're starting to see it in
this opening scene in this opening scene
we see the gin come across the bengal we
see where it is first discovered and
this is the first major point it is
discovered on the severed blue arm of a
cree and the second huge point actually
goes with it and that is the fact that
they said there was supposed to be two
bangles this confirms what i have been
theorizing about since they showed us
the bengal in the very first trailer for
miss marvel it confirms that the bengals
are indeed the nega bands and the fact
that this arm is blue confirms that this
person was indeed a cree so the mega
bans make perfect sense the nega bands
are a powerful cree relic and they are
over a millennia old and they grant the
user the ability to turn their mental
energy into physical energy it's almost
kind of like the green lantern's powers
kind of like if you can think it in your
mind you can create it physically kind
of the same thing here kamala thinks
about turning her hand into a giant fist
and it happens she wants to think about
little platforms that she can step on
well she can make those happen as well
she's obviously got a long way to go
with her powers but we did see a glimpse
of what she can do in this episode where
she turned her arm into a giant fist and
hit four people at once which of course
is mainly what she would do in the
comics by simply enlarging her arm but
the nega bands in the mcu now explain
why they changed kamala khan's powers
and why miss marvel kamala khan is going
to be getting involved in the marvels or
captain marvel 2. but now for the third
really really important part of this
opening scene which connects to the
bigger broader connectivity of the mcu
is that where they discover the bengal
you can see around it the ten rings and
all of a sudden things start to kind of
click the tin rings belong to the
mandarin slash wen wu and the
organization that he formed was the ten
rings and they've been around for
thousands of years and if you recall we
actually don't know where when woo found
the tin rings in the beginning of
xiangxi they say some say he found him
in a crater or stole them from a tomb so
we don't know exactly where he got them
from but in the post-credit of changchi
were made to believe that they
definitely aren't from earth now bruce
banner asks captain marvel if they are
chattari tech and she says that it's not
like any alien tech that she's ever seen
before however in the comics these
aren't exactly just your common artifact
here they were a one-of-a-kind artifact
that not many people would have known
about and they were originally awarded
to captain marvel not captain marvel but
captain marvel by the kree supreme
intelligence and of course in the
opening scene they found the bengal on
the arm of a cree but what is really
really interesting here is that the 10
rings organization had the bengal which
means that win woo had the bengal as
well but decided to hide it and i'm
really surprised that he decided to not
use them but it looks like the 10 rings
were enough for him or he knew something
about the bengals that other people
didn't he might have even been the one
that separated the bengals and hid the
other one or like they mentioned the
british could have taken it or perhaps
the cree or even possibly a skrull has
it right now now how does this all
connect well keep in mind that at the
end of shang chi and the legend of the
ten rings and the post credits scene
wang says that when shang chi put on the
rings for the first time he felt it they
felt it in the commentage and it set off
a beacon and as soon as they mentioned
that beacon captain marvel gets an
emergency alert and has to go and i
wouldn't be surprised if this was
actually connected to miss marvel
perhaps this is taking place at the same
time as that post credit scene and the
bengal is what sent off an alert and
that is something that she has to check
out because remember the cree aren't
good in the mcu maybe some of them are
but for the most part they changed that
comic story about the cree so captain
marvel probably doesn't want the cree to
get their hands on one of the bengals or
both of them now it is possible that the
ten rings are actually cree technology
as well but i am leaning towards no
because they seem like they are kind of
connected more to a mystic energy
because wang felt it at the kamatash he
felt some sort of a specific energy and
i feel like captain marvel would
probably sense if it was cree and the
fact that the ten rings are sending off
a beacon leads me to believe that these
were probably created by some sort of a
cosmic entity and perhaps even in the
mcu the bengals could have been created
by a cosmic entity as well in the comics
they are ancient cree tech but in the
mcu to kind of connect everything and to
keep everything original they often
times change comic origins so i am
really really excited to see how miss
marvel plays out and now i'm even more
excited about the future of the mcu
because it's all starting to connect in
ways that we didn't actually think it
would and there's a lot more to play out
specifically within the miss marvel
story bruno has told kamala that he's
going to be going to california but
kamala asks bruno if he knows anything
about interdimensional travel which yeah
sure no problem for a 16 year old kid
but bruno is actually incredibly smart
and he name drops dr eric selvig and
says that he remembered a book that he
wrote now of course many people remember
dr eric selvig from the first two thor
movies and the first avengers movie and
he had done a lot of research on
einstein roads and bridges or
interdimensional travel and that is
essentially what they are trying to do
here try and travel to a different
dimension or a different realm now in
the comics the mega bands actually do
have the power to kind of go into
different dimensions in the comics the
bengals can take somebody into the
negative zone and in the comics
annihilus actually finds a pair of nega
bands and he uses them to create a
breach in his dimension into the
positive matter universe so like they
kind of mentioned in the beginning of
this episode the nega bands or the
bengals can actually give the user
interdimensional travel some more
multiverse more realm and domain jumping
which seems to be a more common theme
now and of course this was all set up in
multiverse of madness now of course
bruno says that it's too dangerous and
would take too much power it would take
the power of a sun and if you recall
what loki said in the first avengers
film after the very first thor where the
rainbow bridge bifrost was destroyed
loki asked thor how much power odin had
to conjure up to actually send him to
earth since the bifrost was gone making
it seem like it took odin an immense
amount of power to send thor there and
remember that's odin one of the most
powerful gods in marvel and apparently
it took him a lot just to send thor to
earth so the power needed for
interdimensional travel as you can
imagine is a lot which of course
obviously makes it extremely dangerous
and here we learned that komron isn't
exactly a bad dude when he finds out
that it's extremely dangerous he also
finds out that his mother doesn't care
that it's extremely dangerous and that
she's kind of gonna do what it takes to
get the bangle from kamala so him being
kind of a good dude goes and warns
kamala and he tells her that they're
going to kill everybody at that wedding
and comrade actually fights on kamala's
side against his own mother and his own
people so a lot more story to play out
here also nakia has been elected to her
mosque board big congratulations to her
i'm sure we're going to hear more about
this especially because the dodc is
looking for miss marvel and now she has
learned that nightlight is actually her
best friend kamala so i'm sure now she's
really not going to be having a good
time when the dodc arrives again and of
course we have to talk about the end
scene now in this episode where kamala
was fighting off the gin at one point in
time the bengal lights up and najma
manages to grab the bangle at the same
time and they both see a vision of a
train on the train it says karachi and
this of course is connected to the story
that we heard from kamala's father about
kamala's great grandmother her
great-grandmother and grandmother had to
get on the last train to leave however
her grandmother who was just a baby at
the time got lost but she found her way
back to the train by following a trail
of stars now we know that obviously
kamala's great grandmother had the
bengal and she was the one that was
creating the trail of stars for her
daughter which was kamala's grandmother
to get back to the train the reason she
herself didn't get on the train was
because she was helping her people and
what's interesting now is that kamala's
grandmother saw the same vision of the
train that she did and i'm assuming that
her mother is probably connected to this
as well which is why she didn't want
kamala to have the bengal she didn't
want her to know about any of this or
get involved because as she has
mentioned before her grandmother
kamala's great grandmother brought shame
to their family but like i've been
saying it's not exactly all that it
seems but now it looks like kamala and
possibly your mother are going to
karachi and this is going to be exciting
because this is where they're going to
meet red dagger so a lot of really
really exciting stuff coming up for miss
marvel go ahead and let me know your
theories and thoughts about this in the
comments down below and what you thought
of this episode don't forget to give the
video a like and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof